Flying at 30,000 feet you're higher than Mount
Everest, a place where you need an oxygen
tank to breath.
So, why don’t you need one flying from New
York to LA?
Trace here for DNews my frequently flying
friends.
As you go up higher and higher, the air pressure
gets lower.
The ratio of oxygen in the atmosphere stays
the same, but because of the lower pressure,
the oxygen molecules are spread out.
Thus, at over 18000 feet (5.5km), there is
less than half the oxygen available sea level.
Once you're over 25,000 (7km), comfortingly
called the "Death Zone," by National Geographic,
plants no longer take root, and most animals
can't breathe.
At Death Zone heights, oxygen levels are less
than one-third what they are at sea level.
Flying over 8,000 feet (2.4km) without modern
technology, can cause altitude sickness (or
hypoxia) which results in headaches, dizziness,
and eventually vomiting, fatigue, and difficulty
thinking clearly!
It's pretty serious.
But the problem is, airplanes fly best high
up in the air, and people breathe best nearer
to the ground, so to compensate for that low-pressure,
low-oxygen air, the airline industry invented
pressurized cabins.
Today, all commercial airplanes have pressurized
cabins to keep people breathing comfortably.
But, since they don't have tanks of air on
board, they have to supplement the air in
the cabin from some other source.
Jet turbines sort of look like a massive set
of fans, one after another with lots of blades…
Inside that giant engine, air is spun through
fan after fan compressing it, causing it to
heat up, before mixing it with some fuel to
thrust the plane forward.
Because it's compressed by the engines, it
pushes the oxygen closer together, which is
good for the jet to burn oxygen with fuel,
but also it makes it breathable for the passengers
inside.
Before it's burned, some of that hot air is
shunted away from the engine -- this is called
bleed air -- and sent into the plane.
But it's still to hot to breathe -- between
200-250 C -- so, it first heads into the wings
to keep them from icing over, and into the
plane to keep it warm.
Once that's done, the air is cooled to match
the needs of the passengers so it can be mixed
with the cabin air.
And that's it, voila!
"Fresh" outside air!
The excess, "old" air is vented through an
"outflow valve," to keep the cabin pressure
constant.
Of course, there's an unfortunate side effect
of this, at high-altitudes humidity is really
low, and after being heated and cooled a couple
times, the air entering the plane is pretty
much devoid of moisture.
The World Health Organization says airplanes
hover around 20 percent humidity, the driest
place on Earth, Chile's Atacama desert, has
a humidity of 17.3 percent.
Yikes.
The thing is, it might dry your skin and boogers,
but dry air alone ain't gonna hurt you, and
you do get some humidity, from human breathing…
gross, kinda.
New air is being brought in all the time,
and by pressurizing the cabin, and adding
this "fresh" air, airplane manufacturers have
been able to keep us cognizant and alive during
multi-hour flights.
Fun fact, if there's a failure in this system,
those masks drop from the ceiling of the plane
and they are connected to a tank which makes
oxygen.
Please put on your own mask before helping
others, because at 30,000 feet humans only
have about 30 seconds to 2 minutes of useful
function without cabin pressure!
If being trapped in a flying metal tube with
filtered air isn't enough, there ARE places
on airplanes where microbes can lodge and
thrive.
Tara hits you where it hurts in this video
here
Do you have a science question we can answer
on DNews?
I'd love to hear it!